the chief diversity officer of Harvard
University was just caught plagiarizing
her academic work I know I know it's
shocking because Harvard you know would
never be caught up in a plagiarism
Scandal and more to it Chief diversity
officers are held to the absolute
highest academic standards right when I
think of people who get their jobs
through Merit and Merit alone I think of
Chief diversity officers a position that
did not exist 5 years ago and should not
exist cuz it's a Shakedown racket the
woman's name is Sher an Charleston she's
Harvard's first Chief diversity and
inclusion officer of course cuz the
position wasn't real it's still not real
but it didn't even exist on the on
payroll until just a handful of years
ago not only did she plagiarize remember
Claudine gay the recent former president
of Harvard she plagiarized something
like half of her academic work this
woman has plagiarized part of every
single publication that she has ever
written 40 instances of plagiarism in
total